he writes and directs everything the 40
year old virgin and knocked up and I'm
gonna read the whole list he's now the
editor of it's Garry Shandling's book
please welcome Judd Apatow is over here
[Applause]
I couldn't I couldn't tell what you were
insinuating there about Linda greenhouse
it was hard to read into it well so Judd
you're not gonna be all about Bloomberg
oh yeah because I won guest I couldn't
get off that talk that's all I'm going
to talk about the entire timeless
qualities I wanted to talk to Judy more
about her Silent Generation because I
feel I'm first of all I'm fascinated by
generations and also it's obviously so
important in this election that
generations don't agree yes on who
should be the candidate so you have the
Generation X right
I am the Generation X I'm today so you
don't hear about them you know the
Boomers and the Millennials yelling each
other
boomer but like you guys are like what
is it with you what is your
characteristic what what what makes you
gen Express we did nothing we bought the
single for we are the world and thought
we were helping you know watch Phil
Collins play London and New York oh well
I mean that sort of only got worse we're
there or maybe it better I mean your
kids are what gen Z my kids are well 21
and 17 isn't that gen Z that's just so
many of anymore right and what did they
like well yeah you are you were hopeful
for them or no not at all
world is on fire we were evacuated all
week I didn't have a lot of hope as I
ran no you weren't in harm's way with
the fire no I was very close to the fire
oh well we all are you can yeah don't
stare I know but I I do think that my
mother was solo I do think that that
generation cares a lot and I I do they
do think that they're engaged in a way
my generation wasn't okay
so I saw you a couple of weeks ago we
were it's so good you do a lot of
charity and you were doing stand-up yes
and you're really I forgot you were good
stand-up and you think you only went
back to it a few years ago you did this
bit yeah I've been thinking about and I
never did it as I got [ __ ] at always
our thing with comedians he got to that
bit about pictures like people send
their each other yes yes no I think it's
it's all gone too far but I I know I
watched the Shandling special again and
a year and now you have a book about it
and I mean I hope though there are
people here who don't know Garry
Shandling because it's amazing how
quickly yeah people don't remember mash
but my kids have not seen an episode of
mash row on the family The Odd Couple
but they've seen every episode of 90 day
fiancé
[Applause]
and I'm not saying that's worse or
better because I watch with them
but you know he it was a great guy I
mean we all loved him he was sort of a
mentor to so many comics I feel like he
is that why you I'm sort of taken on
that role I mean a lot of people look up
to you in the same way that they did at
a time with Gary like this elder
statesman who knows everything about
comedy is kind about passing it along
yes well I you know the strange thing
you know about this whole experience is
when Gary died someone had to go through
all of his stuff and I was the person
who had to do that and he had all these
journals and there's a moment where you
go like do you read the journal do you
burn the journals and so I kind of vary
and you publish them yeah [ __ ] the
middle step let's get this out to
everybody there is nightmare but but as
I read the journals I realized he was an
even better guy than I thought he was
and you know I open to any page and it
would just say you know maybe comedy is
a gift that you give to people to help
them through this impossible life
expecting nothing in return hmm
and he would write things like that
every day and I thought you know he
struggled a lot he was very neurotic man
but he was really trying to evolve and
and be a good person and you think
that's why he did comedy I mean because
yeah I think he took incredible pain and
he turned to joy for other people and
that's and for him to do I mean I always
it's like when athletes go I did it for
the game no he didn't yeah the game
benefited because you were fun to watch
me do Daffy you I'm not saying he was a
selfish guy I love Gary but you know
well you got to pay the rent bill at
some point but it's just funny that he
was such a spiritual thinker but he's
also wanted to always be in show
business I feel like they don't go
together well that was his conflict
which is right constantly trying to get
rid of his ego and I think the Larry
Sanders show was mocking the part of
himself that wanted my star kind of like
Prince you know
staff was like Jesus is great and I had
a [ __ ] you like sexuality yes
spirituality yeah so Gary's like Prince
that's what we can take away from him
exactly I always say he's like Prince
but with a bigger [ __ ] so
so okay I'm just gonna read a few of
your movies just because I was reading
the whole thing did a super bad wall
card trainwreck Sarah Marshall 40 year
virgin Talladega Nights this is 40
anchorman bridesmaids Cable Guy that's
oh and I was lucky because having done a
few movies a million years ago I know
one thing about movies so many things
can go wrong there's a million things
that can rat fuck'em oh yeah you could
be in a movie with mr. T
[Laughter]
you